depuis le 1er janvier la contraception
est gratuite pour les femmes jusqu'à 25
ans mais attention pas toutes les
contraceptions cette gratuité les
militantes féministes la demande depuis
les années 70 les militantes féministes
de 1971 réclamant toute priorité une
sexualité heureuse et des charges et des
angoisses en problèmes matériels et elle
revendique la contraception libre et
gratuite et la liberté de l'avortement
une sexualité des charges et des
angoisses on problèmes matériels car la
contraception coûte cher aux femmes
alors en 1974 une loi fait de la
contraception une pratique médicale
commune elle peut ainsi être remboursé
par la sécurité sociale ces femmes
positrons - à utiliser des méthodes
contraceptives ce qu'il évitera quelques
ensuite elle est une grossesse non
désirée et recours à une interruption de
grossesse mais la sécurité sociale ne
rembourse souvent qu'une partie base à
100% encore moins les pilules de
dernière génération et c'est un problème
depuis les années 90 le mystère de la
santé a accepté que les nouvelles
pilules les plus sophistiqués ne soit
pas dans le cadre du remboursement aux
trouvant hors remboursement la liberté
des prix les fabricants s'y sont
engouffrés ils s'y sont engouffrés et
ils ont vendu la contraception parfois
hors budget pour certaines femmes une
aberration qui en l'an 2000 fait dire au
professeur nisand que ce remboursement
fait partie de la solidarité nationale
ça sous-entend dans le fond que la
contraception ce serait une
thérapeutique de confort mécanique
médicaments de la prostate ils sont tous
remboursés et s'il y avait pas les
hommes autour des femmes n'auraient pas
besoin de contraception donc pour moi la
contraception fait partie de la
solidarité nationale et n'a nullement à
être déremboursés un pas de plus vers la
gratuité est fait en 2002 la pilule du
lendemain sera délivré gratuitement aux
mineures par les pharmacies ou les
infirmières scolaires vont il m'est
arrivé même de faire crédit un des
mineurs qui avaient besoin de cette
plume pour vous citer une mesure
nécessaire
dispensable
et en 2013 la gratuité de certaines
contraception est accordée aux 15-18 ans
c'était une promesse du président
françois hollande
seuls seront remboursés à 100 poussant
les pilules de première et deuxième
génération ainsi que le stérilet et les
implants contraceptifs
pas forcément et
si jamais on n'a pas envie de dire à ses
parents
ça pourrait être une bonne chose pour
faire face à la diminution de la
contraception chez les jeunes femmes le
gouvernement a donc décidé d'étendre
cette gratuité jusqu'à 25 ans reste que
les pilules de dernière génération les
patchs ou encore les anneaux vaginaux ne
sont toujours pas remboursé
[Musique]